i don't like that
good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day we have
so much to celebrate we have so much to
celebrate first it's hump day so like
let's just get that out of the way most
importantly it's hump day and like you
are about to be
humpy oh oh my god and hum day will be
even more special it will be a
celebration of you oh that's and my body
that's so
beautiful i look forward to that chapter
for me it has been a whirlwind 24 hours
it has been well it's actually been like
a whirlwind three months for us you but
right for me
no but the last 24 hours have been
extremely whirl windy for a girl who's
already been through a whirlwind so i
can say that um as probably most of you
know i announced yesterday on patreon
and instagram that i am pregnant that is
so crazy and it's so crazy to be able to
share it now and i'm i'm so excited to
share it because being in your first
trimester and like going through so many
like physical symptoms and it's so
emotional and your body's changing and
you can't really talk about it like it's
very isolating and so especially to do a
show where like we talk about ourselves
and it's like oh what'd you do yesterday
i laid in bed all day what did like and
i'm right and i'm not just lazy right um
it's very freeing to be able to share it
now so yesterday um i posted a patreon
vlog
of the past three months i started
blogging the day that we took the
pregnancy test because i knew that i
would want you know a memento i knew
that i want to remember this he used to
pray for a moment just like this there's
a fire in your eyes i can't resist baby
we're gonna want to remember this baby
we're gonna want to remember this i
could taste it we're done oh yeah i
thought okay
cool yeah no i think that was a good
place to stop so i posted the vlog
yesterday it's on patreon if you want to
check it out just going through the
three months you know a lot of the
milestones a lot of how i was feeling
along the way it's been very much a
journey you know a gender reveal a
gender reveal yes i am sharing the
gender of my baby because i mean a lot
of people like to tease it out
but i just want to be able to share and
talk about it and i don't have to worry
like oh wait did i give it away like did
i use the pronoun like right yeah so i'm
not going to talk about it today because
i want you guys to go watch a patreon
vlog and like have that moment not spoil
anything yeah i don't want to spoil my
own vlog but head over to patreon.com
morning toast probably the best part of
the vlog is when i told daniel and
rebecca
the best part literally ever i'm
jackie's vlog
and dana in their car
mine was good
[Laughter]
first of all you sent us that video like
when
you took it i didn't realize it was
gonna be part of the vlog and i watched
it one thousand times i don't know where
to look like who's better to look at
written or data cause like dana looks so
funny but rit is so like emotional
it's such a great moment i've rewatched
it 100 times since the vlog came out and
i had already watched it like 35 times
yeah so it was really special because i
didn't get that many people's reactions
on cameras because a lot of most family
i told via facetime because i just
wanted you guys to know the minute that
i knew so that was like nice for me but
you know not great for the vlog the vlog
for the content so um that was really
fun and then i shared a photo of zach
and i with the sonogram yesterday on my
instagram and
and you got 100 000 likes and i got 100
000 likes and that's crazy i didn't see
that for myself that's like half of your
followers no i know and it's like where
have you guys been this whole time
where's that energy when i'm posting
like their straps 100 no like that was
really shocking for me and i just like i
really felt so much love and support and
i got the nicest messages and the nicest
comments and it was a very
it was a very fun day it was also like
very overwhelming and emotional and just
like every day is when you're pregnant
really um
but it was it was really wonderful so
again if you want more content and you
want to know the baby's gender head over
to patreon.com the morning toast and
also claudia and i are going to be doing
a podcast this month like taking all of
your questions so if you have a specific
question for me you'll be able to ask
that in the facebook group claudia will
ask me two things one the facebook group
has just become this like wonderful
place
and everyone's like sharing their
journeys with their kids it's so cute
but the other thing is i just have to
say and i've been like dying to say this
like since
you became pregnant like pregnant jackie
oh is such not that regular jackie is
there's not anything wrong with her
there's nothing like pregnant jackie i
was just like giving me life because
like now you and i like really like
relate on a lot of levels like
everywhere you go you're looking for a
chair like that's literally me
like you're just eating everything like
that's literally me i'm always here like
should we order a pizza and like before
that you were always like let's say one
more shop before we go have lunch you
know like you're always like wanting to
like do the most like and not really
like relax what did you say let's lay
like no like if we're going shopping
like let's hit one more store before we
go have lunch like no let's eat lunch
now how about that okay
so like now you're just like on my level
and i'm just so excited for me yeah no
i'm definitely feeling extremely lazy
extremely hungry all the time
and that's where the journey has taken
me you know every day is different
though every week is really different
like it's funny to watch the vlog and
see how i felt in the beginning what i
like recognized as symptoms versus now
versus like i've had some really awful
weeks the past few weeks so now when
people ask me how i'm feeling i'm like i
feel great yeah but you also like forget
about all the time so you didn't feel
great somebody posted something so cute
in the toast after dark today
from brew
to bro
cause he's gonna be a
brother bruno is going to be a big bro
and
i can't even tell you about this man
brew and i've been trying to tell you
guys
i've been trying to tell you guys like
how close we've become and you know
because he's an amazing man but like
this man brew
has gotten me through the last three
months saying no [ __ ] to my husband i
love you babe but you know he's busy he
works it works yeah bruce job
is protecting mom is protect mom he's
mom's male nurse
and mom needs something bruised barking
for it like he's always he we nap
together every single day he's
constantly looking out for mom
emotionally and physically and i don't
know what i would have done in this time
without brew i i really understand that
i'm so glad that he was there for you in
ways that nobody else could be nobody
else could be did you see the reels i
posted yesterday horse i was sobbing
like
that has been brew and i don't even have
a huge actually i do have a bit of a
belly but it's not like a huge bump yet
that he can like play with um so i don't
even know if he knows what's happening
he just knows mommy needs support and
he's like
we support you
yeah tell me what to do
where when and he and he's hits it out
of the park every time i'm so glad that
he's been there for you because
i don't know
a mum needs her brew
she really really does so
so glad to have that i'm so glad to
share with everyone along the way now on
the show and on the patreon and just
like be more open about how i'm feeling
and you know like maybe you know cut me
a little slack here totally here and
there if i show up like in a bad mood
yeah if i don't show up
no i'm definitely gonna have to learn um
how to start like doing a show alone
like just in case like you're sick like
i don't want to torture you though i
mean i'm at my first trimester so i
should start feeling better so it's like
if i made it through all the other shows
i should be able to make it through the
night that's early
yeah hopefully
this is just like a first like we are
like a female business charter territory
we're gonna have to deal with your
maternity leave like what are we gonna
do we'll figure it out
i'm like googling like average maternity
leave it's like three months take as
long as you need yeah yeah
like i'll literally just sit here with
my titties out like and just read ads
whatever works speaking of i don't know
if it's a story you see only fans yeah
reverse is it a story it is okay so
we'll save it we will i just want that
i've been thinking i really should start
an only pound you should sit on only
fans with your titties out and read out
no no i think that i should well that's
actually a good idea but i think i
should do i think people like
really like to see me eat
who
who don't be so surprised first of all
like i've been going live a lot during
my lunch hour and people are just like
yes asmr and then on my tick tocks like
the ones where i'm eating do so well i
think i just need to start like
eating on camera i don't know that's
where the money is so i've heard
i don't know i don't like it for you i
don't know now you're pregnant you can
join me that's true we can compare
bellies
um
so yeah what else i mean a lot of people
were like thinking oh my god i need to
clear up the biggest misconception
there's been a lot of misconceptions so
do i the biggest one is that your tick
tock is that that's what claudia was
telling ben on the tick tock about a
secret can i tell you that that tick
tock blew up and people started
commenting like you're pregnant or
jackie's pregnant and i wanted to delete
it because i felt so bad cause like you
actually were pregnant but that's not
what i was saying in the video no and
actually claudia told ben i'm pregnant
and it's in the vlog you see his actions
i was in the hamptons you see his actual
reaction yeah so like that really
bothered me because then i wanted to
delete it and then it's like oh my god
an admission of guilt yeah and i was
like wondering if you were going to like
be mad at me and i was like lucky for
you i don't have tic tacs thank god okay
cause like i was drunk and like people
were like starting to comment really
really fast and then people were like
putting it in toast after dark and i'm
like [ __ ] did i do something bad but
like i literally told ben a piece of
gossip about someone i something i heard
about someone we went to college with
like that i used to know in high school
yeah it was like not a big deal people
are so [ __ ] nosy like i know but
people just think like you keep lying
about it and that's what you told him
no i mean one i don't know when you
posted that but like the timing wouldn't
work out of the day like i told family
and two like the actual video because
ben was golfing when i told the whole
family like shapiro was with olivia and
so when ben came home from golf claudia
told him and recorded she recorded it to
send it to me so that's in the vlog and
it wasn't about the tick tock what's the
other misconception the blankets the
blankets is another misconception that
we've been using the blankets to cover
up my pregnancy i mean you guys i'm not
nine months pregnant like no it's also
freezing for like i'm in the stage of
pregnancy of like big lunch yeah yeah
yeah um it's freezing for real i never
thought for a second like definitely
maybe if i'm feeling like
but i only ever have used a blanket if i
was genuinely freezing because i hate
how it looks on the show of course i'm
freezing right now that wasn't that
wasn't a tell okay
um there were a few other things i saw
that there was one day where i did wear
sea bands on the show yes you know what
i was so surprised that you did that
usually i mean there was a bunch of days
where i wore them here and then took
them off before the show but there was
one day i forgot to take them off before
the show and you wear them what for
nausea yeah like for the car ride and
just the actual i even wear them to
sleep like yeah um yeah that was a
mistake
yeah but also like i am just a nauseous
queen like totally catch me wearing sea
bands not pregnant catch me outside on a
boat wearing sea bands yeah sure for
sure and someone said like i offered you
zofran which is like a nausea medication
i've been on zofra i actually haven't
taken zofran since i've been pregnant
jackie's been literally like the zo
friend hustler hustling hey you want us
over here i am a pharmacist yeah and i
am paid by zofran i found a sofa and one
in ben's wallet like you gave him one
once they're so amazing and so no that
wasn't it i only had a zofran because
i'm not taking it right now yeah no and
also um well i wouldn't want to spoil
the q a because we're gonna do like a
big q a but someone wanted to know and
it was actually a fair question like
have you ever tried spritz because i
know i've been pregnant i've been really
excited to share this so i have not
tried spritz from the can since they've
been canned i have not drank a spritz
from the can
in the year and a half where we were
creating spritz we had multiple taste
tests so i've tried earlier versions of
spritz and then like later and we gave
notes and this and that but i never
tried the finished product in the can so
that will be probably like the first
thing i do after i give birth that's
crazy yeah
crazy dm
well we're so happy for you and you know
if you need anything like just let us
know we're very accommodating here at
the morning toes like we follow all the
labor department guidelines like you
take the time that you need if you need
to push push a couple hours i'm
accommodating whatever you need thank
you very much you know so far oh and
thank you for you know exploiting this
journey on our patreon so we can all
benefit yes but also you know it is nice
to have um like these memories to
remember this not only that like the
internet is so disgusting like i don't
know how i have so much respect for
people who just like share their
pregnancy on like free platforms like
that's crazy yeah yeah it's crazy like
there's such a the people who are in
patreon and in the toast after dark are
actual mensches like everyone is a
saturday guest you know yes and i'm not
worried at all but like on the internet
like i just can't believe like that
people are just like always sharing so
much it's admirable because like all
that information people just like i
don't know people are so scary yeah it
is it is scary but then you have like a
nice day on the internet like yesterday
and you're like okay something but you
know then the the mean comments have
important yeah do not even bring that
energy in yeah i just want to let you
know like not that this is about me at
all and that's something i'm working
through i will i will kill someone like
if they if they say one [ __ ] thing
about you i'm just letting you know like
i'm finding their ip address and i'm
taking a [ __ ] plane and i'm going to
their house and i'm having a stern
talking to their mother
good that's the way to get to someone so
you if you want to say something you
mean use ip
[Laughter]
no i have no [ __ ] time like no
[ __ ] time not that i don't i don't
really pers expect people to be
attacking a pregnant lady but those
former toasters man they've done it
before nothing they've done it before
yeah so i'm just letting you know like
you're officially on notice [ __ ] if you
leave one [ __ ] nasty comment on my
sister's instagram in the next nine
months i'm literally coming to your
house
people might just want you to come over
so then they'll start saying okay sorry
i'm just calling your mother great from
a remote location making a cat meow from
your mom
go toast
um so that's the latest with me it's so
nice to have it out there so we can just
like talk about it when i have stuff to
share
um but other than that you know we've
got a job to do here that's true claudia
let me ask you how is your day
do we really care
let's be honest how's dew
sickening he's getting groomed right now
that's why he's not here because it's
sunday but he's gonna look so absolutely
gorgeous tomorrow brew was getting
groomed yesterday that's why he wasn't
here and i would have brought him today
oh my god brew was out the door with me
he walked out the door with me this
morning i was like bro he had his
briefcase and he was like i'm ready to
go he was ready to go but i'm doing
someone else's podcast after this so
you're busy it would interfere with his
um gym so essentially it's podcast
podcast podcast
podcast podcast and if we do the patreon
today we should but also i just have to
say i know this is like not a great time
since we're like sharing positive news a
little scheduling update there is no
show friday or monday because i'm going
to totally ride for me and ben's like
best friend's wedding so i'm really
excited and it's like a western themed
party and i'm just like i'm really
excited
but there's no show friday or monday so
i'm really sorry but the pregnant girl
needs to rest so blame jackie not me no
i'm not complaining take all the time
you need and if it pours into tuesday no
i'm in and out i'm going so fast i'm
going to colorado but there is no show
friday or monday and i deeply apologize
but like literally i went to dinner with
my
friends from high school last night and
they're talking about like weddings
because one of them is engaged and just
like everyone's weddings like are coming
up and some people have rescheduled and
it's like literally i don't have enough
dread there are not enough dresses in
the world for how many weddings i have
to attend and you know that literally
every [ __ ] gown on revolve is on
pre-order they're like out of wedding
dresses because everyone is now we have
talking double the weddings this year we
have last year's weddings and this
year's weddings no i know like it's so
overwhelming like everyone's just
talking about oh you're going to this
wedding this wedding i'm like i can't i
can't no it's a lot it's a lot yeah
plus it's the second to last weekend of
summer so we're using that summer friday
oh that's true we still have summer
fridays yeah and next week too
next weekend's labor day it's just gonna
be a crazy month because it's like
summer labor day there's a bunch of
jewish holidays coming up oh yeah like
rosie shannon is like on labor day oh
i mean i guess you're not gonna really
be able to sympathize with me this year
because you're pregnant you don't have
to fast on yom kippur which is coming up
so fast it feels like literally
yesterday we posted that card 364 days
to yom kippur like
how did how does the i'm so dreading it
yeah you're not gonna have yom kippur
breath you'll be totally fine yeah but i
will have you know pregnancy
i think that's okay i don't know like
honestly like you couldn't handle it no
jackie i keep thinking about like
everything i'm going through and i'm
like how is claudia with my low
tolerance for pain like being so spoiled
and like annoying like i don't know
i think about that all the time okay
trust me it's on my mind
i don't even know if i'll be able to
like like do anything for like 10 months
i know i don't you're you're uh
man amongst boys whatever the phrase is
like you are a hero
no but like compared to and like women
who just go out and live their lives and
like go to work like
we shouldn't have to do that i just want
to say no it's crazy to think about it's
crazy to think about no i know
okay without further ado
where are you getting groomed he's gonna
look beautiful whenever he does show up
because he's he knows there's like you
know big news and he didn't want to like
show up first of all and still spotlight
from you today and second of all he
wanted to you know in your honor look
stunning
when he sees you next thank you dew
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
hydrodrug so many benefits of drinking
water improving your energy gives you
mental clarity can clear your skin and
just overall wellness but 75 of
americans are dehydrated when water is
crucial to your health every cell and
tissue inside your body require water to
function so it's not just any amount of
water with a gallon a day it can make a
really huge impact on your overall
health and since we are in the business
of trying to reduce our plastic use
enter the hydro drug a half gallon of
water
bottle that is so sickening and cute and
it comes with this little sleeve and a
pouch you can put your phone your keys
in it your air pods it's just a great
way to keep you on track all day and it
kind of gamifies the whole thing like
you know
i'm at a quarter gallon i'm at a third
gallon you know things like that keeps
you on track it's really fun i've seen a
lot of celebrities have them and they're
really just cute and they have a carry
loop so it's really easy to carry around
especially with the sleeve it also has
like a strap
it's great it's also dishwasher safe and
bpa free and the bottle is shatter proof
so um
you can take it to the gym you can take
it to work you just bring it with you
everywhere it's like a piece of you and
it just keeps you on track i get really
bad headaches when i don't drink water
so that's why i'm always having
headaches so it's just a great little
item that i feel like everyone needs
especially when we're working from home
you just like plop it on your desk you
could check out hydro jug at the
hydrojug.com and use the code toast to
get 10 off your order today the hype is
real hydro drugs are game changers for
anyone on the go again use code toast at
www.thehydrojug
to get 10 off and start hydrating in
style
thank you i've been loving my hydra jog
especially these days like nothing like
a water bottle by the bed it's a
pleasure
first story kanye west files to legally
change his name to yay
if approved you didn't hear this no if
approved by a california judge kanye
west will legally become yay which is
his stage name he's applied to change
his legal name from kanye omari west to
yay according to documents obtained by
people in the documents he says that his
decision for the change is for personal
reasons and provides no further
explanation okay in order for the change
to occur a judge in california would
need to sign off on the petition
six i don't understand i don't
understand either i'm sure he'll get
the sign off right
yeah i mean people change their names
all the time i don't even know you
needed a judge to do it can't you just
like go to the name changing office yeah
i thought you like go down to the
courthouse yeah i don't know you learn
something new every day about yay
yeah i mean
i feel like he's gone through many a
phase where his name was like jesus and
like
i just feel like this is might be a
phase you know and i know him to make a
long-term decision she's been yay
forever
i just feel like okay that's like your
name is samantha and you want to legally
change your name to sam like who cares i
agree it's totally unnecessary i think
you should have your long name and you
should have your short name can i have
that blanket it's freezing in here yeah
there's one next to you too though
it's not within arm's reach and yours is
oh wow the pregnant lady oh my god
please you're starting
the pregnant lady okay
oh thank you it's so cold so yeah this
is just like kind of like an unnecessary
chop
yeah choppy oh but it is what it is you
know but i'm sure eventually
he'll share
these reasons i don't think so he's got
his reasons
you see lou comes announced today new
song tomorrow brew
south anya sounds so good that does it
just sounds like literally like put me
in a field in the back of a truck and
like i'm going to bob my head back and
forth
and a field in the back of a truck you
know that was so confusing those are
like mixed yeah okay fixed messages
like do you want to be in a honky tonk
no no no it's definitely like an outdoor
festival song and it's like we're all
like because the beat is like okay
so what about like at homedale homedale
like third row let's talk about let's
talk about that okay
no i really you're about to take a big
dump on home dell get out i'm not but
the thing is like when country artists
very rarely tour in the northeast
specifically they tour they do they come
here and they go to either jones beach
or home dell pnc bank okay i'm not
talking about jones speech i'm talking
about pnc art center but if you live in
new york city those are your choices if
you're going to join speech you are also
going to homedale that's the taurus
that's okay i'm just doing that as a
venue will you let me speak no but you
need to have the full picture
i know the full picture a lot of these
artists
will come through to new jersey at the
pnc arts bank center whatever pnc bank
arts center in homedale new jersey it's
an amphitheater and they get like
sickening you know artists because every
country artist makes a stop around here
but they're not going to play arenas
like they're playing in nashville
and i just want to say like it's nice
that like they come
but
i just like that venue is like not doing
it for me i'm sorry i know you have like
a personal interest
in the venue i love that venue i love it
because it's the only place we get to
see country but like
you i just want to be in like in a field
like i don't know i don't want to be
like grand central parkway
get grass seats
then i'm far away
right but no you could go to jones beach
to see that same artist and then you
could be like by the ocean yeah why
don't you do that jones beach is far
jones beach is overrated the idea like
you're literally in this like concrete
kingdom like it's like an old fort yeah
and like you're on the water colosseum
vibes
you're on the water which seems nice but
it's like always freezing and by the way
the concert it's dark out you don't see
the water and it's so far and it's far
but it's pretty probably the same as
homedale i feel like it's not but just
like the ener it's also like the way the
amphitheater is set up versus like on
the water can't hear [ __ ] like you're in
this like fortress i just think jones
beach is really
overeating i saw five seconds of summer
there with ben when they were like such
a small time band and like they only had
like 15 year old father no like 11 year
old followers and me and ben like the
tickets were so cheap it was like seeing
the wiggles like it was like so
like they were not popular and we got
like literally front row seats and we
felt like the biggest losers because it
was actual children everywhere but we
were rocking with our [ __ ] out like we
were like it was so sick and that's the
only time i've ever been to jones beach
that's not true we went to um
we went to a festival there i did not go
and i was right because i said i didn't
want to go no no no no hot 100 that's
something else no billboard no yes
billboard hot 100.
i went with margo and ben and victor
yeah yeah yeah me you margo and olivia
went to a festival
at jones beach it was like a day a
lineup of days i have pictures of you
yes yes yes
yes we saw that girl yeah wait there
were so many people no give me a second
iggy azalea let me sweet hold on we saw
that girl daiya right yeah yeah with the
chat and the chainsmokers or no maybe
she just sang that song just died yeah
you're right iggy azalea
um i think meghan trainor or someone who
looks like her sounds turn we enjoyed
ourselves so i guess i've been to jones
beach twice yeah i'm sure i could think
of more times that you've been there i
saw lady a there with margo and nicole
the snatchers new episodes coming out um
my first concert i ever went to was at
jones beach my first concert i ever went
to was at irving plaza
katy perry evaluated a long time in life
yeah i mean first of all kids these days
are so spoiled i feel like we talk about
this a lot like back in the day going to
a concert was like a once in a lifetime
thing when you were in high school like
first of all you had to ask
your parents to pay for it which like
never [ __ ] happened worse they have
to drive you he's like a chaperone and
then you sit there no totally like it
was unheard of yeah actually
we might have went to hannah montana
best of both worlds before that remember
at like um at nassau coliseum yeah uh
you would have still been in middle
school or high school no but we also saw
glee yeah no katy perry was i i talk
about this a lot but you know i'm like
one of the og katy perry fans that's
funny because like i don't even stand
her anymore but like i was her biggest
fan like i went to an irving plaza
concert with my friend alex brazell who
i talk about a lot here who is a toaster
and we saw katy perry and it was like
just when she had really it's like hot
and cold and like i kissed a girl it was
like a turn show we had the best time
i'm so happy for you so as far as i know
that's the first concert i went to but
hannah montana best of both worlds would
have been before that
no it would have been around the same
time no i think glee was after glee was
such a good show yeah that was a good
time no the best concert you've ever
been to oh i mean nobody does a concert
like rascal flatts nobody true oh my
goodness but the but then also like i've
seen adele like i've seen andrea bocelli
like they're just all so different you
just yeah we've seen stevie wonder you
just can't compare that's true
but nobody throws a concert like rascal
actually
nobody throws a concert like taylor
swift like but also like probably the
best concert i've ever been to is like
stagecoach because then i didn't have to
choose yeah yeah it was like a multitude
of artists yeah even though lanco didn't
play hallelujah nights and like and it
wasn't a hallelujah and that's [ __ ]
disgusting disgusting even though their
album is called hallelujah knights by
the way their song rival is so good you
ain't with me you arrival rival rival
sick such a good song so good i'm like
dying to go to a concert i've actually
been like looking up
so much like country what about kesha
next week no i really want to go to a
country concert okay and the only one
that came was luke bryan and i just like
don't stand i don't but remember we saw
him at stagecoach and he was
unbelievable yeah but like stagecoach
just does something to you no i don't
know we were about to drive an hour and
a half to jones beach just were all
ready to like leave early for luke bryan
and he just has that je ne sais quoi he
has that stage presence for sure he
really really does i think he would have
enjoyed yourself i know it's just not
the same i'm just like i really need
like a luke combs concert it's not for
so long yeah and it's on a monday and a
tuesday and honestly i might have to
take the tuesday and the wednesday off
because like i'm not gonna be okay okay
i'm gonna do molly like make provisions
no of course like i will find a
substitute or we will delay the show but
like i'm doing molly and like you can't
stop me i know the feeling when you just
want to do molly at a rascal flats
concert yes i do i never did it mostly
because like a rascal 5's concert that
just like isn't long enough and like too
good then you're rolling and you have to
get an uber and i've never done molly
and honestly i think i would hate it and
then i would have a bad time at the
louis combs concert which is the
opposite of what i intended to do 100
that's what would happen but i don't
know i still might do it
okay well that was our brief interlude
on concerts oh yeah but kanye good luck
good luck to kanye
the courts will decide next up netflix
is hosting its first ever
ever global fan event bridgeton stranger
things the crown and more will join it's
called to doom a
honestly i don't care what they want to
do like the fact that that's what it is
is hysterical and now i'm going to say
nice things about this
on wednesday the streamer announced
it'll take fans behind the scenes like
never before with
a netflix global fan event airing
september 25th named after the signature
ping viewers here after opening netflix
will unite the production company's
hottest stars and creators representing
over 70 series films and specials on the
virtual stage for an exciting experience
full of exclusives and first looks the
platform said in a statement shared with
people so this is like netflix con yeah
i was gonna say it's like comic-con
netflix con but virtual
yeah which like sucks but i don't know i
think it's cool like comic-con looks lit
but like i've never been interested in
anything even remotely related to comics
except like riverdale maybe yeah um so i
think it's cool like they're opening up
the cons yeah i think it's cool and
it'll be nice because we'll definitely
get like the crown previews maybe
bridgerton season two previews like the
press that will come out of it yeah
they'll have to like do a lot to make it
press is it like live or it's
pre-recorded i'm sure it's pre-req
um
maybe it's live
that'd be cool okay yeah but like all
the hot shows are going to be there so
like maybe there'll be some crossover
like maybe people will fall in love that
to them you think addison ray's gonna be
there
her movie comes out like tomorrow yeah
that's gonna watch it this weekend um
i'm watching it at midnight when it
drops i'm literally so excited okay so
here are participating programs i mean
it's everything bridgerton cobra cry the
crown ozark stranger things and the
witcher also films like red notice don't
look up extraction the harder they fall
and the old guard also series that will
be spotlighted are um
emily like just going through what we've
talked about emily in paris
sex education the umbrella academy
what about vampire academy
no unfortunately okay so just like a lot
of crap
yeah pretty much um
also i don't know if we've spoken about
this here like in your dream world if
they made a movie about evelyn hugo
seven husbands who would play evelyn
um
asa gonzalez got it okay because like
somebody was talking about that on my
instagram live and they said ania taylor
joy and like now i just can't see
anything but her understood for me anya
taylor joy is addie larue you didn't
read the book it's tick-tock famous she
is addy lorrios well i'm done taking
book recommendations from tiktok you
wouldn't ivy larue was far too long and
spends too much time in the 1700s you
would not like it well i have like a
bunch of long flights i have like
actually like four flights this weekend
because it's a one stop
and i need really good books so i think
i'm gonna go with beach read i'll
actually have my list would you tell me
if it's good like what i'll like and
then i'm gonna pull up my list and i'm
gonna give you recommendations okay
so
but i think aza gonzalez would be
amazing for evelyn hugo
just think about it just think about
think about it i still have malibu
rising but like i've actually been
hearing like rare things about it i
don't think you would love it okay so
so i'm gonna do the good sister
okay amazing by sally hepworth yeah we
love i'm gonna do beach read
let me write that
um and then i was thinking of doing that
one lion's den that you said i would
like yeah
i think you could even do lion's den
before beetroot or twice in a blue moon
the redheads one no oh margaret put it
on my list she said i would like it
it's like mind numbing like stupid it's
just
it's fine like but it's not gonna you're
not gonna be like
invested invested okay
okay i'm looking through books i
recently read to see
what i would recommend to you
the hunting wives
okay
put on your list
that's probably the only one it's most
similar
by may cobb by the way you should read
eliza starts a rumor i was going to say
it's like oh my god yes you have no idea
what it's about anymore you never read
it i just would read it out loud to
claudia on vacation to make her fall
asleep by the way that's like when i
really started reading no you started i
was like damn it's like a good book it's
about like facebook groups and like
crazy [ __ ] and facebook groups you
started reading in utah with lucky's
girl live oh lucky squirrel live is a
book that changed my life yeah and then
you took my second kindle and you got
eliza starts to remember what was the
other one um
the hunting wives oh now i'm excited i
definitely want to do eliza starts a
rumor
you really should it was so [ __ ] good
yeah oh my god i love that right now
okay for sure
okay and then um back to netflix
yeah cool like
hopefully one day it'll be like in a
convention center
have you ever been to like any community
i went to uh comic-con once at the
javits center i went to drag con once at
the javits center before i ever watched
one morsel of drag race and i feel like
i totally didn't appreciate the
experience i was on a panel and i was
just like cool like i was just excited
to be like a part of something but i
didn't really understand like how
important the event i was at was and
like it kills me because i have never
been invited back
damn it was awful like i know like it
was amazing and like the fact that i
enhanced it like i didn't even know like
what drag was like yeah so disrespectful
yeah that sucks it's like when we have
someone on the toast and then like
afterwards i watch something that
they've done like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i
have a million questions that's how i
feel about um
chris
what's his name
really hot um hairdresser for kim
chris appleton chris appleton like first
of all i've become such a big fan like
of his work and
also the biggest regret of my life is
like we showed up looking like two rats
who just climbed out of a sewer because
we were going on a flight and we just
had sprayed him we just had spray tans
like we were just doing the episode and
then like getting on a plane to
nashville for the cma awards so we both
looked like rats yeah we did that's my
regret about it like my regret is just
like not enjoy like
being more present in the moment
okay that's okay
yeah and like i feel like my opportunity
like for him to think i was cool and
like maybe offered you my hair once like
gone oh yeah no
oh no
oh no no no no no are you ready for our
next story only if it's the next story
that's brought to you by skylight frames
yes it is nowadays staying in touch with
those we love is more important than
ever and the easiest way to do it is
with a skylight frame a photo frame that
you can email photos to anytime from
anywhere it's a great gift for someone
with a birthday coming up or someone who
just had a bebe or even just for
yourself anyone can send photos to the
frame in just seconds so it's a great
way to keep in touch with friends and
family and when your babies are growing
so much and like grandma lives across
the country and she doesn't get to see
them you need to show them like look
mikayla's getting big like you have to
show
dresses for the grandparents it's also
very easy to set up so if you're not or
like your grandma's not very
technologically savvy it takes a really
short amount of time and it's really not
difficult
takes up less than 60 seconds to set up
and it looks like a real photo frame
that adds a beautiful touch to your home
it has a gorgeous 10 inch touchscreen
where you can swipe through photos with
your finger and even tap to thank the
person who sent the photo they offer 100
satisfaction guaranteed if you don't
love your skylight they'll offer you a
full refund
so when you go to skylightframe.com and
enter the code toast you get ten dollars
off your first off your purchase of a
skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com enter the code toast
for ten dollars off your purchase
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t
f-r-a-m-e dot com code toast
thank you claudia our next story is it's
a pleasure
our next story is really crazy so i'm
going to need you to bear with me okay
so basically you're saying don't
interrupt you it has to do with two
really important entities one is liquid
death which is a water company that is
sponsored a sponsor of this show yeah
and two tony hawk okay
tony hawk is selling 100 skateboards
painted with his actual blood
okay liquid death the water company
which claims to murder your thirst use
code toast has teamed up with tony hawk
to create a limited edition run of 100
skateboard decks infused with the
skating legends blood each board boasts
a vials worth of hawks dna mixed in with
the paint for the decks he said i am
deeply thankful to have a connection
with my fans and i appreciate how liquid
death connects with theirs this
collaboration is taking those
connections to a new level as i have
literally put my blood and soul into
these decks he liquid death said that
they actually own tony hawk's soul he
signed a legally binding contract
selling his vitality to liquid death and
consumers can too if they want exclusive
access to merch and private events so
this reminds me like lil na's ex did a
blood blood in his shoes right because
he did a blood endeavors and people were
like outraged like let's see where the
outrage is with tony hawk um this is
like this is so weird like we live in
such a bizarre culture i'm sorry like
sometimes i'm like you ever take a step
back from the world we live in and be
like what the [ __ ] is going on you know
one of those moments okay all the time i
do like once a day and i uh not today
like i feel like this is obviously crazy
but like if you are a skateboarder like
he's your idol skate is life
no like honestly you want to skate with
the power of tony hawk like
okay like let's gotta get a little
let's say
like i could get you know a microphone
with taylor swift's blood in it like
would i want that no and i'm like
chelsea's biggest fan
it's like gross what if it was also like
in the age of coven we're really
swapping like bodily fluids yep we are
what if it was a guitar painted red and
had a little bit of blood honestly that
sounds sick
someone to think about thank you you've
given me something to think about but
it's just weird like yeah no wait
definitely this is like a trend like why
are we doing this i guess this is what
happens when like your sport becomes an
olympic sport only after your prime you
get desperate
you get desperate you get crazy money
hungry brand deals
and you have these radical ideas this is
nuts this is nuts i think it's like a
bit of satire too yeah you know um but
it's just that crazy tony
guys tony's gone crazy again if only you
let him skateboard in the 2008 olympics
for two people who like couldn't give
less of a [ __ ] about sports and honestly
had like zero influence by tony hawk in
our lives we sure talk about him a lot
he's become extremely relevant ever
since you know he's been slighted yeah
by the international olympic committee
disgusting
until he hit 40.
boom olympic sport disgusting disgusting
i actually i mean i'm sure he thought
about it but i like when we saw the
skateboarding events like honestly it
was pretty amateur it was literally
child's play i feel like tony could have
gotten in there i feel like he could
have beat those snot-nosed kids in two
[ __ ] seconds i wonder if he even
tried
honestly like i i know this is gonna
sound crazy but i think tony hawk
competing in that farce of an olympic
sport would have been like bad for his
image
like him winning a gold sport like
beating out some like you know 11 year
old romanian kid like that's not a good
look
like really you have to go to the skate
park and beat up like little kids to
feel good about yourself tony that's not
how i see it that's how i see it there
was not one person in that competition
over the age of 18. what the [ __ ] would
tony be doing there i'm sorry like well
first of all he went to commentate
and also like he gave his life to the
sport like he deserves an olympic medal
from it i agree just give him one
okay that's no no that's not how it
works no no especially not foreign no no
not for a new sport
are you ready for our next story sure
tom gerardi has been spotted at an
assistant livid
assisted living facility after being
disbarred yeah erica jane's estranged
husband was spotted at the belmont
village senior living facility in
burbank california and on sunday in
photos published by the daily mail he
wore a purple sweater over a blue button
down and khaki pants the black eye that
he sported when we spotted him earlier
this month was noticeably gone okay it
is unclear why the attorney was at the
assisted living home former attorney
um they wouldn't confirm if he lived
there or what but he was visiting a
friend here's now my antennas are going
up because do the paps hang out at the
belmont village assisted living home how
are they knowing where he is and
honestly that's what sutton was kind of
saying
on last week's episode just kind of
being like there's this narrative being
painted like you're kind of supporting
it and so is tom like three years head
injury he's not been the same like there
is this picture trying to be painted of
him for some reason
and this all these quote-unquote
paparazzi pictures first he looks frail
then he has a black eye now he's in a
nursing home like how dumb do they think
we are yeah no i think like i i really i
feel like if i didn't do this job like i
would just read the article move on be
like oh tom's living in a nursing home
you know i wouldn't like have to i
wouldn't have to take the time to like
think
what where'd we get this pic yeah no but
we are investigative journalists also
did he get the black eye at the nursing
home
uh elder abuse
no and like honestly these pictures of
him would be so sad if he wasn't so evil
like you would see these pictures of
like a frail old gentleman like no but
that's what we used to dress so dapper
that's what they're trying to do to you
but we're too smart and so are you guys
don't believe it yeah no maybe he is
living there but like he's living there
for show and things have gotten like
really dark with erica on social media
and like reyna like like of course like
anyone who's sending erica a death
threat is a [ __ ] um but she's like
posting that i don't know she's really
handling all of this in a very bizarre
manner and so it's like lisa arena and
lisa arena is like i feel like if erica
jane released a line of lipsticks made
of her blood like lisa wren would be the
first person in line to buy them the
obsession is like a little weird yeah
it's not even like a friendship anymore
it's an obsession yeah no they're like
mutually bound yeah it's weird
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
it's the final story
gorgeous the note i need to hit is a
little higher maybe i'll get there one
day
you know i'm just feeling like
i've reached the end of my rope with
this triangle like it really doesn't
serve me anymore like i really think i
need like a
banjo or something i literally love this
triangle i think it's such a beautiful
instrument it's also so soothing i
imagine for the podcast listeners like
they love the triangle life oh you know
what i think a bit yeah that's what you
need to do you do need to put like a
ponytail
[Music]
do off so off oh my god flat
okay i'm ready no don't knock the
triangles they're literally the best
thing that ever happened to the show no
i know i can't believe we're the first
podcast to think of having triumphs no i
was saying we're the first podcast to do
a lot of things um i just was saying
like i feel like i've outgrown it in the
sense that i need more i mean no i need
like a trumpet like you need more notes
i need a recorder
no i'm gonna that's not a beautiful how
to play
on the recorder i feel like actually
should be easy okay fine but you can't
bring your recorder here until you've
mastered it because nobody wants to hear
you fumble your way through the recorder
nobody
so mean and so true
until you've mastered it keep your
recorder at home jesus [ __ ] christ oh
my god everybody turning into a mom this
show is for experts only that's true we
talk about things 100 factual no and
like the triangle there's no wrong note
that's true you want to fumble your way
through a
quarter oh my god so dramatic no like
you know that sound no of course it's
atrocious you're right
okay our fifth and final story only fans
has reversed their pornography band
after intense backlash they say the
platform stands for inclusion sorry i
have lost literally every more slow
respect for the people running this
company like if you're going to make a
decision that's stupid like stick with
it
yeah the company told people that the
proposed october 1st 2021 changes are no
longer required due to banking partners
assurances that only fans can support
all genres of creators they said thank
you to everyone for making your voices
heard we have secured assurances
necessary to support our diverse creator
community and have suspended the planned
october 1st policy change
so like i just feel like
it was such a crazy thing to do
and to go back on it like is so losery
but i do feel like last time we spoke
about this i gave them a really good
idea i feel like they should start a
second platform that's the same kind of
you know paying for content but it has
like more strict rules and it's for like
podcasters and housewives and like like
a patreon and should be called only
friends like i just think i think that
was a good idea yeah but why can't it be
only fans
because it has to be a separate like it
has to be distinguished from only fans
why i think they want to make only fans
like more you know less
about like stuff
um also i saw someone message me
yesterday so i'm not sure if this is
true or not but the reason why they
pushed for this move to begin with
is because the banking partners were
pulling their
support because like there were
instances on only fans and i guess
pornhub too where there was like videos
of rape happening oh and
they
couldn't take them down
and the banking partners like did not
want to be involved this has been like a
long
march to trying to
to
stop that from happening on these
platforms
um well that's a problem right so
again some just one person messaged me
that right i haven't seen that elsewhere
but that would maybe explain why they
would do something so radical to begin
with well that's so interesting because
when i first heard about only fans i had
heard that the major benefit of you know
paying for
porn is that when you're watching
something on a free website for porn
like you don't know where it's coming
from and it's oftentimes like people in
those videos are
victims of human trafficking and it's
just like unethical
and
the whole idea of free porn is actually
like
not good so only fans really remediated
that problem like everyone is getting
paid for their content sex workers are
being compensated they're doing
everything you know their own consent so
if that's the case that like content is
popping up that sucks because that was
like the antithesis of why only fans
like became popular yeah interesting
yeah just thought i'd share that yes and
i'd like to share the tv recap segment
which is going to be so painful because
i have reached a boiling point
you hear that
my kettle is boiling because i'm done
with the real hospitals of new york i
think maybe for good wow
the tv recap segment in which i
annihilate the real housewives of new
york franchise is brought to you by
ready slims detox teas
if you want to feel like you have more
energy feel lighter get a good night's
sleep and wake up feeling super
refreshed every morning the secret is
ready slims detox teas they are made
with high quality 100 organic herbs that
gently boost your metabolism and help
digestion while also reducing bloating
and gas
if you want to add it to your healthy
lifestyle you can feel a few pounds
lighter their detox teas are made with
no fillers no additives and no laxatives
so they are safe to drink daily ready
slim's 28 day detox tea kid has
everything you need the wakey wakey
morning detox tea helps boost your
energy levels to help you start off
right and their snoozy night detox tea
helps you relax and support the natural
detox process while you get ready for
your well-deserved deserved beauty sleep
and the best part of ready slam is how
it aids in weight loss plus it's keto
friendly so say hello to a better
brighter you and right now for a limited
time you can save 25 off your first
order of ready slim's 28-day detox tea
kit plus get a free collapsible water
bottle go to readyslim.com
toast and use the code toast that's
r-e-a-d-y-s-l-i-m-dot-com
toast code toast
to save 25 off your first purchase of
ready slim's 28-day detox tea kit plus
the free collapsible water readyslim.com
toast code toast okay so i just want to
say before we dive into last night's
atrocity where like they literally gave
us the most unnecessary to be continued
because nothing happened um rumors first
of all next week is the season finale
okay and rumors are circulating that
today is the real hospice of new york
filming date and they are doing it
remotely
andy cohen has confirmed those rumors
the reunion yeah but honestly why why
the [ __ ] would they spend one more
dollar there would not be one thing to
talk about no i don't think it's about
money
well andy's also on vacation so i'm sure
he didn't want to come back for this
[ __ ] show yeah oh my god that's really
crazy i know yes also do you see the
rumors and we'll get into the episode do
you see the rumors i think was on jumois
that
nbc higher-ups they are
they're changing it up for new york and
pretty much the only two people who are
guaranteed staying would be ramona and
ebony
okay and with louis friend
oh my god she's gonna have a breakdown
friend again i think she likes being
friends i mean obviously everybody wants
to be the star but like she doesn't want
to get her hands dirty on the show she
kind of floats through and like she's
gotten so much out of the um show also
the rumor had said that like nbc now
owns a piece of her cabaret i think in
exchange for her staying on the show
wow that's it her cabaret is very
successful yeah before kovid she was
literally selling out enormous theaters
yeah
so that's what i read anyways no they
there's like there's something going on
because like i think last season of real
housewives of oc was like so bad that
everyone was like we need to shake it up
andy acknowledged it was terrible and i
think compared to what we're watching
right now that season of oc was
incredible
seriously at least something happened
like bronwyn was being nuts and kelly
was being nuts and emily was being like
everyone was being nuts i'm like it
wasn't great but compared to what we're
seeing now i couldn't believe they
pulled it to be continued just because
harry dubin was calling like that's not
the thing the person who man's the two
be to continue sign has lost their
privileges needs to go to to be
continued rehab because they're addicted
to using it in the most mundane of
circumstances when they were playing pin
the lips on the harry duben like my six
brain cells got up and left the chat
like
they
i was losing
brain cells
so dumb everyone like acting like school
girls like i mean good on ebony for even
caring at all and being able to play
this game it was one of the dumbest
things i've ever seen and i so last
night i watched last week's episode plus
this week's episode which i'm glad that
i did because last week's episode was
actually like interesting
the second half of black shabbat yes and
then also just i forgot what else
happened but it was just other stuff
happened it was just a better episode
and then this
oh they all they went to um dinner
with ebony and louis it was just better
and then this episode was mind numbing
the only redeeming thing i'll say about
this episode though is they went back to
ramona's house in the hamptons which i
know you hated i couldn't believe
seriously one season two trips to the
hamptons i know but like seeing all the
the five all the girls go back to the
hamptons like where they are now just a
few months after where they were a few
months ago where it's like ebony is now
such like an integral part of the group
they were all so excited to see each
other and be together and like it
actually looked fun compared to like
when you think back to five months ago
everything was so strained with like
leah and the plasma and the grandma and
like no i didn't think anything about
this weekend was fun it's so stupid like
i thought it was actually really sweet
to show like how far the group has come
in actually becoming friends no and
honestly like
i just can't like first of all i don't
lea has got to talk about something like
this is going to be mean but it's like
in being a housewife like you have to be
multifaceted and part of that is of
course family scenes but like we really
don't care yeah we really don't care we
really don't care about it either leah
is just being insufferable to the women
or talking about her family or with her
family and like honestly i don't know
your family no and also like talking
about your high school antics like we
got we got that last season no it's
really like she's
she has turned out to be in my opinion
like the biggest disappointment in a
housewife like talk about someone no one
has ever had a better first season than
her and talk about like a fall from
grace yeah she's like why isn't she
showing us to like marry to the mob
stuff like why isn't she going out on
dates like something it's just family
and
and women like it's and in the women i
think i i can't i'm disagreeing with her
at every corner yeah so then i'm like oh
you're talking to your mom again like
cool boring yeah
it's just so bad oh my god it's really
bad
but i did think one thing was
interesting when um luanne and ramona
were talking about sonia and they were
like you know we both got divorced and
we accrued wealth and it's true like in
their own ways like with the show and
the platform and instagram and cabaret
like they both
ageless like they have both made a nice
life for themselves and it's like
you can never really put your finger on
like what it is about sonia she's stuck
in this thing and it's because like she
had got the show got this platform and
stayed the same person that she was she
never recruited her own wealth like
she's still in this like money pit with
her townhouse like and i just thought
that was like an interesting take on the
whole thing that ramona said it's true
but i also think like
ramona
is a very apt businesswoman luanne has
been i think she went through highs and
lows and and now she's found her her
spot
sonia like made horrible business
decisions like the toaster oven like you
know even the guy who runs the guy over
here
and it's like okay we'll give you 5 000
of the 10 000. no it's so turned it's so
turned like
it it is really interesting and but it
also goes to show that like it's not a
guarantee the success from the show no
not at all and i actually was just i had
never thought of it that way but it's
true because like of course when you're
a housewife and you've been on for a
while like you make good money from the
show but the real money is and
opportunities outside the show like
endorsements and
i feel like
most housewives do like a pretty good
job of it but like sonya just like can't
get out of her own way no and like she's
she should be so popular famous and
successful like her social media she
isn't only fans like her interns run it
it's atrocious like i would love
you know the job remember big shot with
bethany they need sonia to do that
someone who has like a good hat on their
shoulders who could run her business no
and that's you know what they say you
get what you pay for free interns free
interns and that's the pro the end
result totally
so it was just like last night was was a
dark episode like for all involved yeah
except like i love this new thing
they're doing with the sprinter van
taking it everywhere it's stunning yeah
gotta get the company name no and also
when it was just like snowy and even
leah and her big pink puffer i was like
summer needs to end i know we're
literally winter
winter
winter no i can't wait and i've made no
progress in seeing the snow at christmas
but i'm still working very hard on it
again this is just me putting it out
there if you have any off-market
apartments that you are putting on
market for rent please dm me we also
need to secure some road trips and i'm
thinking newport once again yes newport
in the winter or like fall like how we
did last time i know our outfits were so
sick oh my god it was just so incredible
the bump in newport you'll be bumping in
newport the bump in newport we've got to
take this bump on the road she deserves
it okay who knows the bump deserves like
just bucolic energy
snow fresh air the bump can't ski though
so i got no jackie i'm telling you like
pregnant you and i are going to be best
friends
of course like i've never skated my life
one time and like when we go skiing on
family vacations it's like you ben and
margo like and ben like barely makes it
out the door
now we're gonna sleep in together i'm
gonna miss skiing and then when you have
a baby like you're gonna have to go on
the bunny hill with them like you're
really never gonna be able to they'll go
to ski school
they'll stay with zach they'll say with
zach yeah it's beautiful does that ski
no yeah he's like tried it enough to
know that it's not for him yeah no i i
respect that a hundred percent so
he'll be in the lodge drinking and well
i'll be drinking you'll be eating i'll
be eating for you i'll be in the two
with you too no that's not i would love
to do a ski trip with no skiing yeah i
forgot about that what else can't you do
um gonna miss like you can't have sushi
yeah i haven't had sushi
but you're not like a huge sushi person
i like sushi it's not like i've been
craving it though and also when i when
i'm at a sushi restaurant i just get a
roll with cucumber and avocado and it's
pretty good soy sauce and ginger taste
like sushi yeah um
soda
soda i have a soda when i want one i
just have decaf coffee i have a coffee a
day are you allowed you're allowed to
have up to 200 milligrams of caffeine
and my nespresso has about like 120. oh
okay i used to drink two a day yeah um
also
if i don't have coffee like i will have
a headache and you gotta do what you
gotta do it's not good for mother's
health no and the cavemen like we're
we're fine oh my god that's like what's
so crazy about being like so into
history is just like thinking about and
like
studying like how women
just used to like oh you're not feeling
well here's mine like literally
literally it's so crazy so like
obviously i'm sticking to all the
laws of pregnancy
also the pasteurized cheese thing is
annoying not because like i love
pasteurized unpasteurized what's the
rule you can't have unpasteurized cheese
but it's like everywhere gone like is it
pasteurized and it's like
no but like
are they
i feel like it's illegal to sell
unpasteurized i don't i don't know but
like literally every place that i eat
i'm like is about your eyes and they
have to like go find out and it's like
it is what where do you get cheese like
on your pasta like is parmesan
pasteurized
i'm pretty sure like all hard cheeses
are it's really confusing i just ask
everywhere yeah that's annoying i get it
on my salad you know so it's just hungry
me too what's for lunch
um other i guess like you can't have
deli meats which isn't um i hate it's
not like i eat so many deli meats but
you know a turkey sandwich does sound
good oh you can't have turkey
not unless it's cooked
turkey like thanksgiving yeah
yeah the tryptophan or i could the
tryptophan yeah or you could like heat
up the deli meat turkey which i tried
once but it just
i felt weird after i think it was more
of like an emotional feeling of weird
yeah like microwaved turkey that sounds
disgusting yeah no i tried it um
can't have hot dogs so i'm adding
minutes to my life that was hard not to
talk to
yeah talk about that that was hard july
4th yeah that was really hard because
you know i love a freaking dog um
can't have
can't spray tan
they say you shouldn't spray 10 your
first trimester so that's why i'm like a
ghost um that's been really difficult
honestly that's hard because like a
spray tan would just like clear the
whole thing right now ease all your
worries
[Laughter]
um
what else there's one other thing that i
was thinking that i can't
that had to do with like deli meats or
something
i don't know but
yeah it's just all i eat is carbs carbs
fabulous oh i can't have tuna fish i
don't think which like wouldn't sound
like something i would even want but i
don't know there's been a few times
where it's like i want to tune a bagel
yeah no i feel like you pretty like you
like tuna pretty i do like treat
inflammation so like and it's just hard
to find like sources of protein like i
don't want a piece of salmon
send it back no i had it for dinner last
night and it was honestly atrocious my
friend margaret ordered spaghetti and
like i've never regretted my life
decisions more yeah so like it's just
hard for me to get sources of protein um
about like a filet mignon can you have
that yeah
you should order that i should well i'd
rather like go and have it at the
restaurant because like
delivered flame in the end just doesn't
cut it i agree delivered period just
would you go to a kosher restaurant and
like have a carnivorous meal i would
love to do that lunch
let's make a reservation i'm very hungry
well i'm so excited for you to just
continue your journey with us you know
and just again can't reiterate like if
you ever need anything the toasters are
here for you so am i like if you need to
push off a day like sleep in you just
let me know
okay thank you more than accommodating
thank you so much and that's our show
thank you guys
more pregnancy content head to
patreon.com session morning toast for
the vlog and the rest of the month we'll
be doing really fun stuff that we have
planned so
head over there join in on the fun it's
good times
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show we
deliver the fast life stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast blocks all the places so
whenever you listen to podcast five nice
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
beautiful stunning and smart we are
beautiful stunning and smart we are
beautiful stunning and smart we are
what song is that
we're singing is it's like it is it's
like a jewish song no it's like
[Music]
what song is that dude
[Music]
make sure to leave the triangle emoji on
our instagram to let us know that you
made it to the end of the episode
and that you love the triangle
we love you guys have a great day love
you bye